[музика]
вітаємо і Ласкаво просимо до програми
Європа У фокусі Мене звати ліс шу Ми
раді що ви приєдналися до нас сьогодні
передвиборча кампанія у Польщі зараз у
розпалі у середині жовтня Країна має
обрати новий парламент правляча
націоналконсервативна партія право і
справедливість бореться за збереження
своєї більшості проводячи кампанію
насичену критикою на адресу ЄС словесні
атаки спрямовані також на лідера
ліберальної опозиції Дональда туска він
колишній президент Європейської ради і
головний конкурент на цих
виборах одна із гарячих тем кампаній
права жінок опозиція хоче їх покращити
лібералізувати права на аборти та
запровадити державну фінансову підтримку
для лікування безпліддя натомість
правляча партія право і справедливість
хоче зберегти те що вона називає
традиційною сім'єю вона хоче обмежити
право на аборт і виступає проти
фінансування лікування
безпліддя для таких жінок як Агнешка
костанчак войчик такий крок зробить
народження дитини практично
[музика]
недоступним Рита з'явилася на світ на
початку вересня вона жвава допитлива і
добре їсть усе про що тільки можуть
мріяти
батьки а для її матері гшки це ніщо інше
як
диво початок це така радість ми досі
насолоджуємося цим відчуттям
благословення
Рита справжня радість для мене і мого
чоловіка диво почалося тут за девть
місяців до народження рити у центрі
екстракорпорального лікування
безпліддя тут під мікроскопом
демонструють як яйцеклітина
запліднюється
сперматозоїдом так з'явилася на світ
Рита
до цього як і багато інших пар Її батьки
роками намагалися зачати
дитину навіть із екстракорпоральним
заплідненням у середньому лише одна із
трьох спроб стає успішною але кожна
процедура оплачується і це дорого у
Польщі кожен цикл екз коштує близько 3
000 євро це занадто багато для більшості
молодих пар каже директор клініки ідеаль
було якби
жавіще було би ідеально якби ці
процедури поністю відшкодовувалися як в
інших
країнах
па у випадку маленької рити місто
покрило принаймні половину
коштів для нас це було дуже важливо тому
що вся процедура коштувала дуже дорого а
місто оплатило половину
рахунку Це нам дуже допомогло Я думаю що
це допоможе іншим людям які захочуть
взяти участь у
програмі
до
програ Це також може допомогти Польщі в
цілому населення країни старіє а рівень
народжуваності знижується сотні тисяч
пар не можуть зачати дитину екз або
штучне запліднення може дати їм шанс
близько 10 років тому у Польщі насправді
існувала програма підтримки подружніх
пар які бажають мати дітей але
правоконсервативний уряд скасував цю
фінансову допомогу тепер представники
парламенту виступають проти екз дехто
навіть називає це розведенням
людей субсидії на виробництво людини чим
фактично і є процедури
екстракорпорального запліднення - це не
спосіб вирішити проблему безпліддя
потрібно дбати про продовження роду
людського припинення державної підтримки
має реальні наслідки для цього центру
екстракорпорального запліднення не кожна
пара яка могла б скористатися лікуванням
може собі це дозволити - каже Роберт
гізлер медичний директор
Цет їм доводиться шукати гроші зазвичай
просити своїх рідних або ж скорочувати
витрати в інших сферах На жаль за нашими
оцінками від 10 до 15% пар ніколи не
отримують подальшого лікування з
фінансових
причин ліберальна Влада Вроцлава не
бажає миритися з такою ситуацією і
підтримує лікування безпліддя з власного
бюджету Вроцлав фінансує програму
екстракорпорального запліднення уже роки
ніше можна було отримати фінансування
лікування від Польської держави і з
політичних причин уряд більше цього не
робить але ми хотіли б дати людям такий
шанс це питання гаряче обговорювалося
під час польської передвиборчої кампанії
члени Партії право і справедливість
затяті противники екз Вони знаходяться
при владі на національному рівні з 2015
року але у Вроцлаві перевагу має
ліберальна партія громадянська платформа
ця партія має має найбільші шанси
витіснити чинний польський уряд на
наступних виборах частково завдяки своїй
позиції щодо лікування
безпліддя Я за свободу вибору і хотіла б
щоб усі такі медичні процедури
фінансувалися
державою ми запитали правлячу
консервативну партію Чому вони
виступають проти екз і відповідно проти
способу збільшення народжуваності рівень
якої падає ми зробили кілька письмових і
телефонних Запитів але так і не отримали
відповіді
однак відеозапис віце-прем'єр-міністра
Ярослава качинського дає зрозуміти його
позицію ситуація така молоді жінки
вживають стільки ж алкоголю скільки і
чоловіки тому і немає
дітей мама рити хотіла б щоб якомога
більше пар отримали доступ до лікування
безпліддя і змогли втілити свою мрію про
дитину в життяна сподівається що
наступний польський уряд допоможе це
[музика]
зробити політичний клімат у Франції
напружений із початку року країна
спостерігала загальнонаціональні
протести проти пенсійної реформи та
заворушення через жорстокість поліції
усе це підживлювало невдоволення людей
владою місцеві політики такі як Крістіан
оргаль відчувають на собі весь тягар
настроїв яких стає дедалі більше він
став мішенню після того як житель його
села монжуа не погодився з одним із його
рішень як мера незважаючи на погрози та
залякування політик стоїть на своєму
знайомтеся це крістіян оргаль уже с
років він віддано виконує обов'язки мера
монжуа невеликого селища на півдні
Франції але Останнім часом він стоїть на
лінії вогню в запеклій
суперечці
цей тхір - це нібито я Вони розмалювали
все село стрілками що вказують на мій
будинок побачивши їх Я зрозумів що
ситуація стала небезпечною для мене і
моєї
родини кампанію проти мера розпочав
місцевий фермер який хоче започаткувати
тут бізнес він хотів щоб цю колишню
комунальну дорогу знову відкрили фермер
каже що мер елітаристи нічого не знає
про сільське
господарство на Ютубі він грає
сільського француза в береті та картатій
сорочці чоловік розповідає про
вирощування вовняних
свиней фермера супроводжує підтримує на
відео Папа сіто правопопулістський
ютубер Він говорить про британську сім'ю
через територію якої проходить ця стара
дорога це спочатку окситанія і тільки
потім
Франція в окситанії і англійці це
підтвердять у нас тут більше симпатії до
диких кабанів ніж до
англійців стара дорога пролягає через
сад
сінклерів кілька тижнів тому їхній
будинок облили червоною
фарбою мер підтримує британці який живе
тут багато
років
я не думаю що зробив щось
погане Це був дуже важкий
період ми з дружиною пережили сильний
стрес і Нам навіть тоді довелося
з'їздити в лікарню звісно я
сердитий я не заслуговую на те що
сталося Я не зробив нічого поганого як я
вже
казав у дома мер намагається віднайти
спокій у
малюванні для нього здаватися - Це не
вихід те що відбувається в монжуа не
поодинокий випадок кажуть
експерти напади і погрози в бік мерів у
Франції
почастішали іноді від радикальних лівих
але частіше від
ультраправих що стосується мера монжуа
то тут ми маємо справу з представниками
ультраправих радикалів ідентитаристів і
прихильників теорії змови
це рух який ставить під сумнів
легітимність обраних представників і
намагається послабити і дестабілізувати
їхню
владу Для цього вони використовують усі
доступні
засоби зокрема і YouTube Папа сіто
викладає своє відео у сатиричній обгорці
люди в цьому кліпі розігрують сцену в
якій жорстоко нападають на мера якого
зображено у вигляді цього плюшевого
звіра
[музика]
подібні відео набирають сотні тисяч
переглядів у результаті на адресу мерії
монжуа надійшли сотні погроз секретарка
була
приголомшена Чесно кажучи я ніколи в
житті не бачила нічого подібного раніше
були невеликі розбіжності але щось
подібне для такої маленької спільноти Це
божевілля Ми зв'язувалися з фермером
кілька разів але прохання про коментар
залишилися без
відповіді так я знаю але зараз у мене
дуже багато роботи ненависть в інтернеті
впливає навіть на особисте життя мера
його дружина каже що часто не
почувається вдома у
безпеці я більше не запрошую до себе
онуку через постійні гутки машин
вечорами Але я розумію коли мій чоловік
каже ти хочеш залишити Такий світ своїм
дітям і онукам
для оргаля це питання того хто головний
обраний міський голова чи право радикали
і він не збирається
здаватися Якби ж тільки всі хто живе в
демократичному суспільстві вирішували
конфлікти за допомогою цивільного
дискурсу Румунія країна з найбільшою
кількістю бурих ведмедів у Європі вони
здебільшого живуть у Карпатах і можуть
становити реальну загрозу для людини
було кілька випадків коли ведмеді
нападали на людей калічили чи навіть
вбивали їх після зустрічі з бурим
ведмедем Костянтин бадеско залишився зі
шрамами Але на щастя живий він часто
дивується як необережно інші румуни
поводяться із
ведмедями ці дикі ведмеді живуть біля
цієї гірської дороги у румунських
Карпатах автомобілістам дорога відома
завдяки так званим ведмедям ракам які
сидять на узбіччі і чекають щоб їх
нагодували за кілька кілометрів ми
побачили 10 бурих
ведмедів вони також і біля цього кіоску
з їжею і є Вагома причина остерігатися
їх у нас перенаселення ведмедів у
пошуках їжі Вони підходять ближче до сіл
до будинків Зазвичай вони не становлять
небезпеки але люди іноді поводяться
нерозумно підходять до них занадто
близько і трапляються погані речі
годувати ведмедів вважається
нерозважливим вчинком і багато румунів
обирають один із двох таборів з одного
боку затяті Захисники ведмедів з іншого
люди які хочуть щоб ведмедів
відстрілювали Єлена бадеско вже рік живе
у страху перед ведмедями і вона щойно
помітила свіжі
сліди погляньте ці сліди із
суботи дивіться бачите які вони великі
майже рік тому чоловік Єлени зіткнувся з
ведмедем Він показує нам місце де це
сталося înțțiici aici a scos
capul Я впав обличя
вниз Бо якби впав на спину і він
накинувся б на мене Ось так Це була
проблема
рани Константина вже загоїлися але вони
залишили свій слід Він не збирається
кидати роботу через ведмедів але після
того інциденту походи до лісу вже не
такі як
раніше коли ійду сюди Я сильно
шумлю відомо скільки бурих ведмедів живе
у Румунії навесні Міністерство довкілля
повідомляло про 8 000
особин Рубен Йосиф вважає що ця цифра
завищена у Румунії немає
загальнонаціонального наукового
моніторингу ведмедів
Рубен біолог дикої природи з екологічної
організації фонд збереження Карпат він
щодня шукає сліди ведмедів сліди кіхтів
і шерсть на території яку він досліджує
Минулого року було нараховано 290
ведмедів один-два волоски виглядають
багатообіцяючи адже вони досить товсті
колір виглядає свіжим і головне що ми
шукаємо - Це цибулинку де знаходиться
ДНК вона міститься в корені
волосини цей зразок поїде у
лабораторію аналіз покаже чи занесено
цього ведмедя до каталогу чи ні
пізніше Рубен знаходить нові
сліди біолог виходить на слід ведмедя
який втратив страх перед людьми слід
привів до цієї
[музика]
ферми мер тоадер Маріан запитує фермера
Йона мусетеску чи були напади і Чи бачив
Він ведмедя останнім
часом вони тут щоночі
Ведмідь прийшов сюди з території за якою
спостерігає Рубен
Йосиф і це було небезпечно тому мер
Маріан мав
діяти його кілька разів відганяли Він
став
агресивним І 31 травня я як мер прийняв
рішення відстрелити
його якби це вирішували вони було б
відстріляно набагато більше
ведмедів у Румунії дехто навіть закликає
винищити половину популяції це було б 4
000 бурих
ведмедів повернемося до біолога дикої
природи рубена Йосифа він встановив
камери ці кадри допомагають
задокументувати маршрути міграції
ведмедів Минулого року на такі відео
потрапили дві дорослі
тварини
уздовж туристичної стежки Рубен
знаходить ведмежий послід явна ознака
того що ведмеді неподалік Рубен бореться
за те щоб люди краще співіснували з цими
тваринами і він погоджується з
відстрілом ведмедів лише в одному
випадку потрібно знати наскільки велика
проблема з ведмедями що ми можемо з ними
зробити і які профілактичні заходи
повинні застосовуватися щоб переконати
що мипере стали привчати ведмедів до
сіл ведмедів вздовж цієї гірської дороги
також частина проблеми і незабаром їх
можуть почати відстрілювати міністр
екології вже визначив 220 ведмедів які
підлягають
відстрілу наш наступний репортаж
перенесе нас на Шпіцберген архіпелаг між
материковою частиною Норвегії та
північним полюсом у його Головно місті
нгр проживає близько 2 000 людей але
навіть у цьому віддаленому регіоні війна
в Україні дуже відчутна тому що там є
російське поселення мешканці якого
лояльні до Путіна це постійне джерело
напруженості наближаємося до архіпелагу
Шпіцберген на крайній півночі Норвегії
регіону де досі живе дух фронтиру його
найбільше місто лонгір часто називають
найпівнічнішим населеним пунктом на
землі але навіть тут люди відчувають на
собі наслідки війни в Україні Роні
брунвол очолює віit свальбар місцеву
туристичну агенцію до війни вони
працювали разом із російською громадою
пропонуючи тури до сусідніх населених
пунктів зараз усі зв'язки
розірвані це були такі тісні стосунки
між людьми і між компаніями тому коли
все Це почалося у лютому 2022 року
звісно ситуація між
була
напруженою ми відвідуємо арілда ольсена
мера лонгіра Це невелика громада в якій
живуть люди з різних куточків світу
Шпіцберген - це частина Норвегії але
згідно з договором підписаним у 1920
році росіяни як і інші народи мають
право жити і працювати тут протягом
багатьох десятиліть усе ішло добре але
тепер ольсн побоюється що війна Росії
проти України може призвести до
конфліктів і тут одна з причин за його
сло ломи у тому що багато жителів
російських поселень поширюють
кремлівську пропаганду Я бачу що те ж
саме що іде від офіційного Кремля також
іде від офіційного
баренсбурга те саме в іншій формі але те
ж саме і я бачу що у баренсбурзі і в
Кремлі працює одна і та ж
пропагандистська
машина наприклад 9 травня жителі
російського поселення баренсбург
влаштували Парад Перемоги у військовому
стилі
такі дії на норвезькій землі багато
місцевих жителів розцінюють як
провокацію ми вирішуємо поїхати до
баренсбурга щоб побачити повну картину
влітку з лоніра туди можна дістатися
лише на човні баренсбург з його
вугільною шахтою і туристичною
індустрією повністю належить російській
державній компанії раust arc
уголь Руслан Сафін працює в цій компанії
Як і всі тут він розповідаєк змінилося
життя у поселенні після введення санкцій
проти
Росії Ну по-перше коли вводилися санкції
тоді ніхто не думав про такі місця як
Шпіцберген як на мене це дуже нерозумно
тому що тут дуже специфічне
місце в тому числі і у сенсі логістики
доставки якщо перекриють всі кордони
зупинять поставки то тут може бути
простокологіч
кастрофа і ті опоненти не думають про це
не прогнозують подальшого розвитку
ситуації прогнозирую дальнейше развитие
ситуации вони кажуть що у них досі
хороші стосунки з іншими народами на
шпіцбергені що нічого не змінилося з
початком війни в
Україні але ми також чуємо що туристів
стало менше І що постачання продуктів чи
певних товарів стало
проблематичним проте більшість людей з
якими ми розмовляємо зокрема ірек
місцевоїли кажуть що вони щасливі що
живуть тут на крайній півночі Норвегії
каких-то таких
жстких якихось таких жорстких конфліктів
протистоянь тут
немає я так припускаю що люди є
різні точки зору
різні розуміння подій
різне але стосунків ніхто не
з'ясовує усі розуміють що ми знаходимося
на цьму
острові ні в кого немає можливості
кудись піти в бік треба вміти
домовлятися на концерті на честь
місцевих шахтарів патріотичний
російський підтекст може справити інше
враження Арктика з її ресурсами і новими
морськими шляхами має важливе значення
для Кремля який намагається розширити
тут свій
вплив Росія хоче інвестувати більше
грошей у нові дослідницькі проекти та
туризм але зараз баренсбург досить
ізольований частина працівників виїхала
повернувшись до лонгєра ми зустрічаємося
з однією з таких робітниць Дар'я
арнаутова родом зі східної України вона
виїхала з російського поселення після 10
років коли почалася війна в Україні каже
що більше не могла там жити з самого
початку було дуже багато хто з України
які підтримували Україну і вони Так же
само як і ми розривали свої контракти і
почали від'їжджати з беренсбургу
але дуже багато людей
які виходці з України ДНР
ЛНР але вони підтримують
Росію конфлікт триває каже даря
арнаутова як показує зростання
напруженості на країні півночі війна в
уїні має наслідки в регіонах які Кремль
можливо і не
передбачав англійські газони вважаються
взірцем садового мистецтва не дивно що
газонокосарку винайшов саме британець і
зараз деякі любителі спорту з
задоволенням використовують Ці машини
для зовсім інших цілей хочете вірте
хочете ні але на півдні Англії щороку
відбувається перегони на газонокосарках
і так це справді так шалено і гамірно як
і звучить
А на сьогодні це все більше історій ви
можете знайти на нашому сайті І в
соціальних мережах і з вами була лісшу
до зустрічі у наступному випуску Європа
У
[музика]
фокусі
forign